Speaker 1: We are taking calls via discord David
Pakman dot com slash discord. Just a reminder,
if you want to get on your nickname, must
be your name and where you're calling from
or where you're calling from and your name,
you know, just names alone or nicknames or
stuff like that is not likely to get you on.
Let's go to Rodney from Saint Louis. Rodney
from Saint Louis. Welcome to the program.
Speaker 3: Hey, David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Okay, great. First of all,
I want to say congratulations on last week, a
week and a half ago when you had the right wing
attack and you and your audience was.
Speaker 2: Able to rally. We made.
Speaker 1: Up. We made it,
Rodney. I appreciate that.
Speaker 3: Yeah, it was amazing. Just got
me thinking that obviously the number one
thing that we all run into on every
single issue is the money, power,
interest. And every single time the media doesn't
ever cover it, and it's not really covered that
much even on independent media. But I would think
if maybe I don't know if you and like Sam and Jane
Curtin and others on the left ever get together
and like try to like, use your audiences to.
Speaker 2: Strategically get.
Speaker 3: The word out or even
acknowledge that the left media is even existing.
Speaker 1: Yeah, you know, we really don't and
we should. The last time I saw Jenkins, Sam was
like, in the same place I saw Sam more recently,
but the last time the three of us were in
the same place was at a conference in Vegas,
like right before the pandemic. And I'll be
honest, this this particular issue did not
come up. It was really kind of a social thing. We
went to dinner. But I actually do think, you know,
one of the things I've talked about before, and
I think you're kind of getting at this, Rodney,
is that when it comes to funding independent
media and creating this sort of like under.
Underbelly sounds negative, but in a sense it's
an underbelly. It's a layer, we might call it,
of a media, to really try to get young people to
come to our side right when they leave college.
The right funds that to an insane degree. I mean,
I recently heard I don't know if this is true,
that turning point USA raised like $40 million or
something like that and the right has way more of
these right wing think tanks, whether
when you join, you're much better paid
than if you're on the left and you join like
whatever the left wing equivalent would be.
So I actually think there would be a lot of value.
It doesn't have to be, you know, me along with
Jenkins, Sam, but somebody and I'm willing to be
a part of it. And obviously Jenkins Sam would be
great people to have involved as well. We need
to just make really clear, like listen to some
degree, like there's not actually a mystery about
what's going on here. We're winning on so many
of the issues. When you ask people their view on
abortion, their view on gay marriage, their view
on using taxes, all these different things. So
it's very clear the left is winning on the issues,
but we simply aren't doing what we need to do
in terms of funding the messaging and the right
crushes us on this. And for all the talk about
George Soros is George Soros has never funded me
or any of the people you mentioned. And it is
something where if the left they're ghosting.
Speaker 3: You.
Speaker 1: Guys, they're ghosting 100%.
Speaker 3: I mean, when's the last
time you seen AOC or Bernie talk about
David Pakman or Twitter or the majority
report? The 100% that needs to happen.
Speaker 2: 100% has to happen.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And I think we
need to have more advocates in Congress and we do
have some, you know, ro con as a big advocate and
I think to some degree like Eric Swalwell and I
can certainly name people, but you're up. So this
is a huge systemic problem. It's bigger than
me. JENKINS Sam, But to the extent I can be
a part of solving it, I'm glad to be.
Speaker 3: Yeah, you guys are just in
my wheelhouse. Yeah. You know, I agree
with 99% of what you guys talk about,
and I love it. Are you going to do a great job?
Speaker 1: Thanks so much, Rodney. Great. Great
call and great topic. Thank you. All right. There
goes Rodney. Let's take just a very quick break,
just to let cooler heads prevail. No, I'm
kidding. We just need a quick break. If you're
still wanting to talk to me, just hold on because
we're coming right back to the phones after this.